- [Voiceover] Johanna jogs
along a straight path.
For zero is less than or equal
to t is less than or equal
to 40, Johanna's velocity
is given by a differentiable
function v.
Selected values of v of t,
where t is measured in minutes
and v of t is measured in
meters per minute, are given
in the table above.
We see that right over there.
Use the data in the table
to estimate the value of
not v of 16 but v prime of 16.
And we see here, they don't
even give us v of 16, so how
do we think about v prime of 16.
Well, just remind ourselves,
this is the rate of change
of v with respect to time
when time is equal to 16.
So, we can estimate it, and
that's the key word here,
estimate.
We can estimate v prime of 16
by thinking about what is our
change in velocity over our change in time
around 16.
And when we look at it over
here, they don't give us
v of 16, but they give us v of 12.
They give us v of 20.
So, let's figure out our
rate of change between 12,
t equals 12, and t equals 20.
So, our change in velocity,
that's going to be v of 20,
minus v of 12.
And then our change in time is going to be
20 minus 12.
And so, this is going
to be equal to v of 20
is 240.
240 v of 12.
We see right there is 200.
And so, this is going to be 40 over eight,
which is equal to five.
And we would be done.
For good measure, it's good
to put the units there.
So, this is our rate.
This is how fast the velocity
is changing with respect
to time.
So, the units are gonna be
meters per minute per minute.
So, we could write this as meters
per minute squared,
per minute, meters per minute squared.
And we're done.
Now, if you want to get a
little bit more of a visual
understanding of this, and
what I'm about to do, you would
not actually have to
do on the actual exam.
Well, let's just try to graph.
Let's graph these points here.
Let me give myself some space to do it.
So, if we were, if we tried
to graph it, so I'll just do
a very rough graph here.
So, let's say this is
y is equal to v of t.
And we see that v of
t goes as low as -220.
It goes as high as 240.
So, let me give, so I want
to draw the horizontal axis
some place around here.
T is positive.
It would look something like that.
And so, let's just make, let's make this,
let's make that 200 and,
let's make that 300.
And so, then this would be 200 and 100.
200 and 100 there.
And then that would be -100.
And then that would be -200.
And then that would be -300.
And we see on the t axis,
our highest value is 40.
We go between zero and 40.
And so, these obviously
aren't at the same scale.
But this is going to be zero.
If we put 40 here, and then
if we put 20 in-between.
And so, this would be 10.
Let me do a little bit to the right.
That would be 10.
And then, that would be 30.
And so, what points do they give us?
So, they give us, I'll do these in orange.
Zero, comma, zero.
So, that is right over there.
They give us when time is
12, our velocity is 200.
So, when the time is 12,
which is right over there,
our velocity is going to be 200.
So, that's that point.
When our time is 20, our
velocity is going to be 240.
So, when our time is
20, our velocity is 240,
which is gonna be right over there.
And then, when our time is
24, our velocity is -220.
So, she switched directions.
So, when it's 24.
So, 24 is gonna be roughly over here.
It's gonna be -220.
So, -220 might be right over there.
And then, finally, when time
is 40, her velocity is 150,
positive 150.
So, at 40,
it's positive 150.
And so, these are just
sample points from her
velocity function.
But what we wanted to do is
we wanted to find in this
problem, we want to say,
okay, when t is equal to 16,
when t is equal to 16,
what is the rate of change?
And we don't know much about,
we don't know what v of 16 is.
But what we could do is, and
this is essentially what we did
in this problem.
We could say, alright, well,
we can approximate with
the function might do by
roughly drawing a line here.
So, if you draw a line
there, and you say, alright,
well, v of 16, or v prime
of 16, I should say.
So, v prime of 16 is going
to be approximately the slope
is going to be approximately
the slope of this line.
That's going to be our best
job based on the data that
they have given us of estimating
the value of v prime of 16.
So, we literally just did
change in v, which is that one,
delta v over change in t over
delta t to get the slope
of this line, which was
our best approximation
for the derivative when t is equal to 16.